Générique
...
Musique intrigante
-C'est un succès,
on ramène du résultat.
-Ouais, c'est surtout ça.
...
-Toutes ces personnes ont un point
en commun :
elles travaillent
dans les centres
d'expertise et d'essais
de la Direction générale
de l'armement, la DGA,
une entité-clef
du ministère des Armées.
Nous irons, dans ce numéro,
à la rencontre d'hommes et femmes
au savoir-faire unique.
Exceptionnellement,
nous avons suivi
leur travail
dans ces lieux singuliers,
rarement ouverts au public.
...
La DGA est créée
par le général de Gaulle
en 1961, un an plus tôt,
la France se dote
de l'arme nucléaire.
La politique extérieure
de la Ve République se veut
plus indépendante et volontariste.
Le général de Gaulle entame
de cette façon une transformation
en profondeur du paysage
de l'armement français.
-Nous avons décidé d'avoir
ce qu'il nous faut,
et d'autant mieux et d'autant plus
que cette puissance nucléaire,
comme on dit,
est liée directement
à l'énergie atomique elle-même,
qui est,
comme vous le savez tous,
le fonds de l'activité de demain.
-La force nucléaire
devient alors un enjeu
stratégique et prioritaire
pour la France.
La DGA tient son socle.
Si la France fait partie
des grandes puissances mondiales,
notamment sur le plan militaire,
c'est que la DGA a su développer
des programmes ambitieux
tout en anticipant les conflits
de demain.
-Ces missions,
c'est d'équiper les forces armées
et de préparer le futur
de notre défense.
Concrètement,
c'est 10 500 hommes et femmes,
ingénieurs, civils,
militaires, techniciens,
qui sont disséminés
sur l'ensemble du territoire
puisque nous avons une dizaine
de centres d'expertise et d'essais.
-Dans le sud de la France,
un drôle d'oiseau navigue
dans les airs à proximité
du mont Ventoux.
A bord de cet avion,
des personnels de la DGA :
le commandant Guillaume
et l'ingénieure de l'armement
Magalie réalisent des tests en vol.
Pendant plusieurs jours,
le binôme, qui a suivi
une formation exigeante au sein
de la prestigieuse école EPNER,
enchaîne les vols et en exploite
les données pour améliorer
l'aéronef sur lequel
ils travaillent,
le Rafale F4.
...
Le Rafale est un des avions
de chasse emblématique
de la France.
Au début des années 1980,
l'armée de l'air
et la marine nationale doivent
renouveler leur flotte
vieillissante
avec un nouvel avion de combat
capable de remplir plusieurs
types de mission.
L'industriel Dassault Aviation
travaille alors sur l'élaboration
de ce biréacteur.
...
En 1991, il fait l'objet d'un vol
de démonstration
à l'occasion du salon du Bourget.
...
Le Rafale intègre le service actif
au début des années 2000
avec, comme premier
standard opérationnel,
le Rafale F1.
...
Au cours de ces 20 dernières années,
la DGA n'a eu de cesse
de l'améliorer.
Le Rafale F2 succède
rapidement au F1
et intègre la capacité
de frappe au sol.
...
Le F3 bénéficie ensuite
d'une évolution de ses réacteurs,
d'une meilleure furtivité
ainsi que d'une capacité d'emport
de missiles dernier cri.
Le chasseur est mobilisé
sur plusieurs théâtres d'opération,
en Afghanistan,
en Libye, au Mali
et en Syrie.
...
Cela fait quatre ans
que le personnel de la DGA
travaille sur un nouveau standard,
le Rafale F4.
Ses améliorations doivent
permettre à l'avion français
d'entrer dans l'ère du numérique.
Depuis 2023,
un premier appareil est soumis
à de nombreux tests.
...
Sur la base aérienne d'Istres,
le personnel navigant
du centre DGA Essais en vol
s'apprête justement
à l'éprouver.
Ce sont des experts
du domaine aéronautique
et ils explorent
les limites des avions
ainsi que de leurs équipements.
-Nous mettons nos pilotes
ou nos personnels navigants d'essais
qui sont ingénieurs ou techniciens
à bord des aéronefs,
nous les mettons dans des situations
très risquées qui leur demandent
et qui demandent
au processus qu'on met en place
de la rigueur,
de l'agilité, de l'autonomie,
beaucoup de lucidité.
-Nous travaillons
sur l'arrivée du standard F4.1
du Rafale,
le dernier standard développé.
Actuellement,
on fait un focus spécial
sur le viseur de casque,
une des capacités
nouvelles du standard F4.1.
-C'est un casque,
porté par le pilote,
qui comporte une petite lame
qui va devant l'oeil du pilote
et sur laquelle
on vient projeter des symboles,
des symboles qui peuvent
porter sur de la navigation,
donc des paramètres de vol
pour aider à se repérer
dans l'espace,
ça peut être aussi des symboles
plaqués sur l'environnement,
qui entourent un avion
dans l'environnement
ou un objectif sur le sol
et ça peut aussi permettre
d'envoyer la direction
du regard du pilote
dans le système
d'attaque du Rafale.
Donc l'aéronef,
c'est le Rafale B359,
c'est un F4.1.
Il y a pour ça une constellation
de petites pastilles
sur la verrière,
on appelle ça des fiduciels,
qui dialoguent de manière optique
avec le casque
via une petite caméra
avec des centrales à inertie
pour repérer
en tout temps la position
de la tête du pilote dans le cockpit
et donc d'afficher les symboles
correctement.
On va vérifier en particulier
la précision de la ligne
de visée du casque,
on va par exemple viser
des points au sol.
donc par exemple, hier,
on a visé l'antenne
au sommet du mont Ventoux.
-Dans la conduite de l'essai,
dans le vol,
on est complémentaires.
Le pilote amène l'avion
dans les points,
les positions,
les éléments de vol
utiles au recueil des données
et l'ingénieur valide
ce qu'on appelle
les points d'essai,
s'il a eu,
oui ou non,
les résultats nécessaires
pour ensuite pouvoir
passer à la suite
et pouvoir avoir au débriefing
tout ce qu'il nous faudra.
C'est un casque avec lequel
on adore voler,
parce qu'il démultiplie
les capacités, vraiment,
du Rafale en intégrant l'oeil
du pilote ou du navigateur
dans le système d'un Rafale.
*Résultat sur le point 3 gauche,
euh, sur 45 degrés,
une grosse variation
en place avant.
Euh, ce serait intéressant
de noter le timing,
et de regarder
s'il se passe des choses.
-D'être en salle d'écoute
nous permet d'avoir
les retours à chaud du pilote
et de répondre en direct
à ses interrogations,
de gagner du temps et de créer
des liens de confiance
aussi avec les pilotes
et la visière.
...
-En vol, ça s'est pas passé
exactement comme on le pensait.
Avec l'industriel en salle d'écoute,
c'était précieux
de pouvoir discuter
et expliquer ce qu'on voyait
pour diagnostiquer le souci,
et peut-être nous donner des clefs
pour corriger.
Notre travail,
c'est de réduire ce nombre
d'inattendus,
de les cartographier
et surtout de les améliorer
et de les corriger
s'ils doivent l'être
pour poursuivre
la campagne et fournir une capacité
pleinement opérationnelle
aux forces.
-Guillaume et Magalie vont continuer
les essais jusqu'à maîtriser
les risques avant la livraison
de ce Rafale F4 aux armées.
...
Les savoir-faire de DGA
Essais de missiles permettent
de réaliser des tests
sur des engins balistiques.
Un des équipements spécifiques
du Rafale F4 est le missile MICA
nouvelle génération.
-Le missile qui est employé
par les forces sur le Rafale,
il va falloir pouvoir l'utiliser
en toute sécurité et, pour ce faire,
il va falloir vérifier
que le missile, sa structure,
est capable de supporter
cet effort d'éjection
du lance-missile sous le Rafale.
C'est cette éjection,
avec les contraintes associées,
que nous allons réaliser justement
dans cette tour de chute.
-Il y a deux façons de propulser
le missile MICA nouvelle génération,
soit en bout d'aile,
ou bien sous le fuselage du Rafale.
Sur le site Gironde,
ingénieurs et techniciens
s'affairent au banc d'essai EB-3,
une tour de 21 mètres de haut
qui permet de simuler
la chute d'un missile.
-La particularité qu'offre
cette tour est d'avoir
des grilles très solides,
permettant d'éviter au spécimen,
donc par exemple un propulseur,
de s'échapper de l'air,
s'il devait être initié.
Et c'est des infrastructures
très appréciées par nos partenaires
industriels car toute la sécurité
d'emploi des spécimens en essai
est garantie par l'expertise
de la DGA.
-Cet essai a nécessité une grosse
phase de préparation en amont,
un an et demi à peu près
de définition
d'un portique qu'on a fixé
dans la tour de chute
dans laquelle on travaille,
on fait un essai maquette en amont
avant de passer
sur l'essai avec un propulseur
actif pour tenter de trouver
des solutions à tous les problèmes
qu'on a en amont.
-Afin de simuler un tir de Rafale
en haute altitude,
le MICA nouvelle génération
est placé
dans un congélateur
jusqu'à atteindre
une température négative extrême.
...
Quelques heures plus tard,
le missile est
sorti de son caisson réfrigérant,
les équipes DGA ont
30 minutes pour réaliser l'essai.
Dans ce laps de temps très court,
les techniciens accrochent
le missile au lanceur,
placent un matelas dessous
pour ne pas endommager
la maquette.
L'alerte est donnée
et tout le personnel se replie
à plus d'un kilomètre de distance.
-Si j'enlève les bouchons,
je peux envoyer
des gens dans la tour,
si je les mets,
je peux plus les envoyer
dans la tour.
C'est une barrière de sécurité.
Les éléments qui retiennent
mon attention sont les bouchons
de sécurité,
un élément indispensable
pour que mes personnels
soient en sécurité
pendant l'essai d'éjection,
on a quand même des risques,
ne serait-ce que si la maquette
arrivait à chuter,
et les bouchons permettent
quand ils sont mis
qu'il n'y ait pas d'ordre
qui puisse être passé
ni par le poste
de commandement de tir,
ni par les équipes MBDA,
pour éviter tout problème.
*-Faudrait peut-être
un petit peu redresser
en rotation vers la gauche.
-Les caméras ultra-rapides
situées tout autour du dispositif
doivent permettre d'exploiter
à distance les données de l'essai.
C'est l'objectif principal.
*-Rien à redire, je crois.
3, 2, 1, top,
numéro 1.
-C'est pour ça que je veux pas
prendre de risque du tout.
Bon, allez, on bâche.
-On s'est rendu compte,
au cours de ce déroulement,
que nos caméras ultra-rapides
n'enregistraient pas,
sachant que ces caméras
sont des mesures
qu'on appelle prioritaires
car elles permettent de reconstituer
la trajectoire du missile éjecté.
Donc le directeur d'essai
et les responsables
des autres équipes
ont pris la décision
de ne pas aller au tir tant
que ce problème n'était pas résolu,
ça fait partie
des mesures prioritaires
pour ensuite analyser
les performances du missile.
-On aurait préféré tirer ce matin,
après, ça fait partie
de l'essai,
on va investiguer cet après-midi,
on va essayer de trouver
d'où vient le souci
pour pouvoir aller à l'essai
de manière optimale.
-Journée difficile
pour Floriane et ses équipes,
mais c'est leur persévérance
qui enrichit les protocoles de test.
Quelques jours plus tard,
tous les capteurs de mesure
sont fonctionnels,
l'essai va à son terme
et donne des informations
précieuses quant à l'éjection
du missile par le Rafale F4.
Sur la base aérienne 118
de Mont-de-Marsan,
les militaires
se préparent à accueillir
un nouvel avion de chasse.
Il s'agit du Rafale F4
sur lequel
le binôme de DGA Essais en vol
a effectué les tests
et que Magalie vient livrer
au Centre d'expertise
aérienne militaire, le CEAM.
-On travaille
en équipes constituées
et la preuve en est,
comme vous avez pu le voir,
il y a le conseiller DGA
du général commandant le CEAM
qui est en ce moment
dans mon bureau et avec qui
on échange au quotidien pour avancer
sur de nombreux dossiers,
parmi lesquels figure
le standard F4
du Rafale.
-Identique.
-Désormais, les personnels
navigants du Centre
d'expertise aérienne militaire
vont pouvoir
réaliser des tests opérationnels,
autrement dit,
ils vont véritablement évaluer
ce dont ce nouveau Rafale F4
est capable pour le combat aérien.
...
-Les améliorations apportées
par le standard F4.1
nous permettent d'avoir
une meilleure connaissance
de la situation tactique,
de mieux nous adapter et aussi
de mieux communiquer
avec nos armements
et enfin d'être mieux protégés.
DGA Essais en vol va inviter
des personnels de mon équipe
à venir voler pour faire
des vols de constat
dans lesquels on va mettre
l'avion dans une situation
opérationnelle, le but étant
qu'on puisse faire une photographie
du développement de l'avion,
savoir où il en est
et éventuellement
discuter avec les industriels
des modifications
qui seraient vraiment nécessaires
pour aller jusqu'à la qualification.
-En quoi est-ce un confort
pour nos forces de première ligne ?
Eh bien c'est que chacun son métier
et elles, elles n'ont pas
du tout à se soucier
de la fiabilité du matériel
et de comment utiliser
ses capacités au mieux,
tout ça a été fait en amont
à la fois par les équipes de la DGA
et puis par nous, CEAM,
qui vont fournir le mode d'emploi.
-Tout ce qu'on fait,
c'est pour l'utilisateur final,
qui est le militaire.
On travaille donc beaucoup
avec les centres
d'expérimentation des armées,
c'est le lien naturel entre
le système qu'on finit de qualifier
et celui qu'ils vont récupérer.
-Cet appareil est sorti d'usine,
mais qu'en est-il
des anciens Rafale ?
Jusqu'à quand pourront-ils voler ?
Quelles sont leurs limites ?
Pour trouver des éléments
de réponse à ces défis techniques,
la DGA utilise
des structures innovantes.
-Nous avons une mission
de maîtrise d'ouvrage
essentiellement technique
parce que nos projets
ont une prédominance technique
d'innovation très forte,
des projets ambitieux
techniquement.
-Et donc notre défi
est de pouvoir intégrer
des innovations technologiques
à cycles très courts
dans des opérations
à cycles très longs.
L'innovation technologique
fait partie de l'ADN de la DGA.
...
-C'est à Toulouse,
berceau de l'aéronautique
depuis que Clément Ader
a inventé le premier aéronef,
que la DGA a implanté
son centre d'essais
Techniques aéronautiques.
Dans ce centre
sont testés tous types
d'avions civils et militaires,
dont le Rafale mais également
les équipements de vol.
Parmi eux,
le casque que portent
les navigants,
c'est un élément crucial.
En raison des contraintes
physiques exercées en éjection
de cockpit, la moindre
modification d'équipement
peut avoir de grosses conséquences
sur la sécurité du personnel à bord.
-En fait, ce qu'il faut comprendre,
c'est que,
quand on s'éjecte, sur Rafale,
on subit une accélération
entre 10 et 20 G donc le poids
du casque prend une importance.
-Pour mener à bien ces tests,
le centre d'essais
Techniques aéronautiques
dispose d'une technologie
quasi-unique au monde.
-On se trouve
dans l'installation d'essais
windblast,
soufflerie impulsionnelle
qui reproduit le choc aérodynamique
quand le pilote
va passer la verrière,
puisque c'est ici même
qu'on va piloter ces essais.
-La soufflerie a été
mise en service
dans les années 90.
Elle comptabilise
plus de 3500 essais,
soit près d'une centaine par an.
Sonnerie
-Cinq, quatre,
trois, deux, un.
...
Aujourd'hui, on a vu un casque
de vol Rafale standard.
On a déjà qualifié le standard F4
avec viseur de casque Thales,
c'est quelque chose qui est acquis,
notre installation était
au coeur des essais associés
à la qualification
de ce nouveau dispositif.
On se doit d'avoir
une réponse technique
pour répondre
aux enjeux d'aujourd'hui
mais surtout futurs.
On a décidé de développer un banc
d'essais associé au windblast,
un rail d'éjection positionné
devant la soufflerie
et qui reproduit la composante
ascensionnelle d'éjection
dans ses premiers instants,
c'est unique
par son architecture technique.
Ce qui me motive tous les jours,
c'est de travailler
pour la survie
des pilotes de chasse.
J'ai à coeur de bien
faire mon métier.
-Autre spécificité de ce site :
les halls Concorde et Airbus.
La cellule Essais fatigue
éprouve les avions
en soumettant un vieillissement
accéléré des ailes,
parfois même jusqu'à la rupture,
pour vérifier la marge de sécurité.
-Les industriels vont mesurer
leurs systèmes
juste pour prouver que ça marche
et nous, on va prendre ces systèmes
et les pousser jusqu'au moment
où ça ne marche plus,
pour aller voir
jusqu'où on peut aller.
-Voilà, l'idée,
ce serait d'aller regarder
comment on peut faire
pour démonter
un vérin qui est à l'extrados
et au plus près
de l'emplanture.
-La modélisation de cette structure
en trois dimensions
autour du Rafale a demandé
quatre ans de travail
aux ingénieurs du bureau d'études.
Puis les techniciens ont
créé la structure
métallique et peuvent
désormais la modifier.
-Donc le vérin, c'est le ZE,
qu'il faut que vous démontiez,
et donc regardez
ce qu'il va falloir
démonter en amont pour pouvoir
sortir le vérin.
Je m'entoure de tous les acteurs
nécessaires au bon
fonctionnement de l'essai.
Dès qu'on a en charge un essai,
on monte une équipe projet,
qui sont le bureau
d'études,
l'entité montage,
l'entité hydraulique,
l'entité pneumatique,
le pilotage de l'essai,
les mesures en essai
et je suis un peu
le chef d'orchestre
de toutes ces entités.
-Pour répondre
aux demandes d'essai,
les techniciens
hydrauliciens peuvent
se rendre dans la cathédrale,
un parc à vérins où ils piochent
parmi les 1500 pièces
entreposées.
-Actuellement,
on m'a demandé justement un vérin
d'une course de deux mètres,
comme ici, pour un autre essai.
Donc le service montage
va le récupérer
pour après pouvoir l'installer.
C'est un parc très riche,
pour répondre
à diverses demandes,
que ce soit nous,
hydrauliciens, pour répondre
aux différents efforts possibles,
mais aussi pour le bureau d'études
et les divers ingénieurs.
Sur un petit calibre,
on en a pour deux ou trois heures.
Les plus gros vont
prendre bien plus de temps.
Ca prend en compte aussi le côté
réparation des joints,
nettoyage,
plus la phase de test,
qu'on a avec cette machine,
qui nous rallonge
un petit peu le temps.
On découvre
chaque jour de nouvelles choses.
-A présent,
le vérin défectueux
est réparé et les essais
peuvent se poursuivre.
Régulièrement,
la DGA et l'industriel
réalisent des inspections.
-Bonjour, Nolwen, ça va ?
-Bien, et toi ?
-Oui, ça se passe comment ?
-Donc je contrôle
le bord d'attaque du Rafale,
c'est les rivets
qui sont tout le long.
On utilise des ultrasons
permettant d'aller dans la matière,
comme les échographies.
Je vérifie qu'il n'y ait pas
de fixation cassée.
-Ce Rafale était neuf
en arrivant.
Mais après le travail
de la cellule Essais fatigue,
il se retrouve aujourd'hui être
le plus vieux de la flotte.
-On doit maintenir
une feuille de route crédible
pour l'aviation de chasse française
et tout ceci montre que c'est
un travail en continu
avec l'industrie pour pouvoir
arriver à avoir
des équipements
qui nous permettent d'éviter
ce qu'on appelle les ruptures
de capacité opérationnelle.
Il se trouve que le Rafale
est un excellent avion,
j'ai toute confiance qu'il aille
au-delà de son potentiel
donc oui, ça donne de la souplesse,
ça donne une flotte riche,
qui permet d'attendre
les nouveaux systèmes
qui arriveront
à l'horizon 2035-2040.
-A cette échéance,
le Rafale n'appontera
certainement plus
sur le porte-avions
Charles-de-Gaulle
mais sur un autre
mastodonte des mers.
Initialement installé à Paris,
au coeur de l'actuel
ministère des Armées,
DGA Techniques hydrodynamiques,
désormais situé en Normandie,
est un des plus vieux
centres d'essais.
Il a participé à la construction
de nombreux navires grâce
à des moyens uniques en Europe.
-Nous sommes
au sein du bassin de traction
Emile-Barillon, 600 mètres de long,
15 mètres de large,
7 mètres de profondeur,
pour des tests de maquettes.
De par ses dimensions
et ses caractéristiques,
ce bassin est
quasi-unique en Europe
et parmi les plus
performants au monde.
-C'est un bassin de traction,
c'est-à-dire que c'est
une énorme piscine
au-dessus de laquelle
il y a une plate-forme,
qui peut rouler sur des rails
et qui tracte des maquettes
comme celle-ci.
-Sur ce bassin navigue
à faible vitesse un engin
de près de 11 mètres de long.
Il s'agit de la maquette
du prochain porte-avions
nouvelle génération.
Pour étudier sa manoeuvrabilité,
la maquette est bardée
de capteurs de mesures
et de plusieurs hélices.
-La vie d'une hélice commence
dans le bureau de l'ingénieur,
quand on reçoit
le cahier des charges,
toute la phase de conception
où on crée
la géométrie, on la transforme
pour qu'elle soit adaptée,
une fois que c'est figé,
ça part ici chez nous
au bureau d'études,
qui sort les plans de l'hélice
et une géométrie bien propre
pour que ce soit exploité
par les techniciens et ouvriers,
qui fabriquent alors
à échelle réduite
une hélice pour qu'on puisse
la tester ici.
-Ici, vous avez donc une des pales
qui va venir construire
l'hélice.
Si on veut utiliser
de la machine-outil,
on risque de créer des arêtes
ou de manger la forme
beaucoup plus vite
qu'on le souhaiterait.
Plus c'est lisse
et moins l'eau viendra
accrocher sur le propulseur.
Il est vraiment nécessaire
de travailler manuellement
plutôt que d'utiliser
une machine-outil.
Cet outil,
c'est un outil qui est
fabrication maison,
une transmission
de savoir-faire
dont on n'a pas trouvé
d'équivalent dans le commerce.
Une fois ces étapes terminées,
on va aboutir à un résultat
comme celui-ci,
le poli miroir.
On est bien sur une surface
lisse et homogène.
-J'ai toujours été frappé
par la complémentarité
entre les ingénieurs,
qui vont faire des choses
extrêmement techniques,
pointues, sophistiquées,
et des artisans d'exception qui,
du point de vue de la technique,
vont faire des choses extrêmement
pointues et sophistiquées.
L'alliance des deux
nous permet effectivement
de faire des choses uniques.
-En plus des futurs
standards Rafale,
le porte-avions nouvelle génération
accueillera à bord
des drones de combat.
Tous ces éléments collaboreront
et communiqueront ensemble.
C'est ce que la DGA appelle
l'hyperconnectivité
et le SCAF pour Système
de combat aérien du futur
en sera un des piliers.
-Pour vous donner une idée,
le porte-avions nouvelle génération,
quand il sera mis à la mer,
en 2036 ou 2037,
on sera plus à la 5G,
on sera à la 15G
ou communication quantique.
C'est aujourd'hui qu'on doit
préserver de la place
dans ces opérations
pour intégrer
ces innovations à venir.
Le combat collaboratif,
c'est l'avenir du combat,
en tout domaine, naval, terrestre,
aérien.
Le Système de combat aérien du futur
est un avion de nouvelle
génération qui est entouré
d'ailiers dronisés, robotisés,
qui vont donc communiquer
entre les capteurs,
les effecteurs qui vont pouvoir
s'échanger de l'information.
-Grâce notamment
aux plateaux de simulation SCAF
et laboratoires connectivité,
la DGA permettra
aux corps opérationnels
d'avoir une meilleure perception
du champ de bataille
dans son ensemble.
La gestion et le partage de flux
d'informations de plus en plus
importants sont des enjeux
majeurs pour les armées.
Ces hommes et femmes,
qu'ils soient ingénieurs,
militaires
ou techniciens ouvriers,
font preuve d'audace et ont recours
à l'innovation pour assurer
la sécurité des armées
et cet objectif est atteint
en grande partie
via l'implication de la dizaine
de centres d'expertise
et d'essais de la DGA.
-Si on n'avait pas
nos centres d'essais,
d'expertise et d'essais,
il y a nombre d'experts techniques,
on ne pourrait pas réaliser
cette mission aussi bien.
Donc ces centres d'essais sont
le gage de l'autonomie stratégique
de la France en matière
de système d'armes.
-La France se prépare désormais
à contrer de nouvelles
menaces dans les champs
cyber et cognitifs,
dans les grands fonds marins
ou encore dans l'espace,
de nouvelles zones de conflictualité
que la DGA a investies
avec toujours un seul objectif :
préparer la défense de demain.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA